Right so this should be
a relatively simple example,
very tiny little example,
but it may be challenging.
So here's what's going to happen.
We are in a little four-room museum, and
we're interested in together
exploring the museum, but
the first thing we have to do is
actually end up in the same place.
So we each know what state,
we are in state four by the way, but you
don't know which state the other person
is in, you know where I am for example.
I know where I am, but
I don't know where you are.
We win if we end up in the same state
you can go basically north, south, east,
west or stay put, and if we're going to
move simultaneously, if I turn ends,
and we're both in the same
place we win okay.
>> So normally you would have to issue
these commands into the environment.
Right?
You walk around by yourself.
But you need to tell me what, what
you're going to do, so I can keep track.
>> Okay, and all I can do is move north,
south, east, and west?
>> Or you can stay put.
>> Or I can stay put?
>> Yeah
>> Okay.
>> And for
what it's worth in the DEC-POMDP model,
It's a planning problem.
So we can actually make
up a strategy in advance.
As long as we don't use it
as part of the strategy.
What state where, we're starting in,
because we don't know that.
>> So we can talk about
what our strategy would be?
>> Yeah.
>> Well I can think of sort of
three classes of strategies.
>> Okay.
>> So one would be one of us decides
never were to move so that the let
the other person move around.
>> Good.
>> That way we can't just miss it to
other right, and so I could not move or
you could not move right.
I should see those two separate things.
The other one would be we just agree on
a set of actions that we will take that
guarantee that we will
end up in the same state.
>> Well and maybe one way to do that is,
we'll pick out like a focal point will
pick a room that we should both go to.
>> Right, I was thinking three
because three is my favorite number.
>> Nice.
Okay.
So,
which of these strategies
do you suppose is better?
Well, It depends on exactly how rewards
and discount factors are defined.
>> Yeah, that's true.
But if we just think about cost somehow
being how long it takes us to get there.
>> Okay.
>> I actually guess.
Going to the same room is
probably the best one, because
no matter where you are long as you can
either take zero two steps to get there.
One step to get there or
two steps to get there.
>> Good, good I think you're right
actually, so let's do that so
we defer to sign in advance that we're
going to converge on room three.
And you wake up, and
you find you're in room four to start,
but I don't know that.
But I know what room I'm in, and
now we both get to choose an action.
>> And I would choose the action left.
Assuming we aren't in the same room.
I would choose the actual left.
>> Okay.
All right, and
I will tell you that I
put you in room three.
and I take an action that is trying to
also move me towards room three, and
it worked.
>> We're both Room three.
>> We're both there are three.
Hey what you want to see first.
>> Room three.
[LAUGH]
>> This is the Salvador Dali room.
>> Excellent.
>> All right, so this worked out
actually really well for us,
because you can imagine if this is
a much more complicated domain,
if there's a lot of stochasticity
if our task was more complicated.
It might be very difficult
to know what to do.
For example, what if you thought
you were in room four, but
you were actually in a room two.
And because you know partial
observable states being what they are.
So, you might not even know that
you're not in room three yet, and
it might be very difficult to get
there and know that you got there.
>> Well, I would hope that
there would be some room
>> Where we know whether
we're in that room or
not you never sure.
I dont know I mean whenever you do this
in a real museum right that's what you
do look just meet you at the entrance.
>> Well I thought it was
the Jurassic room, but
it was actually the Cretaceous room.
>> This is where pick an intruder
the entrance or something.
>> I see.
Yeah like a good focal of so
like one like the entrance.
>> No three was the answers as weapons.
>> All right.
Done and done.